hey hello everyone i think i am live
um hi how are you as you guys can
probably tell
this is not caleb uh this is um
this is uh videomaster i guess i should
call myself phil masterfield master
italia cervantes
uh you guys may know me from some other
um
twitch streams or um even some youtube
streams
i have so um yeah caleb is not here
today you guys are stuck with me
so um yeah so welcome to
road to 2000 uh this is my first time
teaching the class and i'm very excited
as i am above um
and uh today what i have planned
is as you can probably read from the
title is a game
about building up the initiative
building up the attack
not giving chances to the opponent and
attacking with the bishop player
um and this is from a this game that i
have picked is from
a tournament that i played i finished
playing a couple of days ago like two
days ago i actually got back home
um yesterday and i played a
a i am norm invitation in charlotte so
in the charlotte chess center so um
so yeah um
but yeah let's let's probably
get started with the with the game
uh okay
so and this is on this only chess and i
kind of planned to do it on leeches
for all of the all of the
lectures that i have today um
i don't know if some other format may be
better but i did plan to do them on
only leeches so yeah
but all right uh we should probably get
started with the game i was white pieces
here
and i am playing against esra chandler
chambers
uh he actually goes to webster
university so he's from from town
um i just hadn't played him before
uh and it's it's very surreal to like
play chess in like an actual tournament
again
like you know with an opponent in front
of you that you can
uh you know see their expression feel
their lives
and that can influence the game so it's
really really nice you know to have
the the opportunity to to do that again
not very often of course but you know
it's a good chance um all right so
let's get on with the with the game i am
a d4 player i play
i started with d4 d5 c4
c6 not f3 knight f6
this is a slav
e3 and a6 a6
is still a very popular move however i
feel like most people know the semi-slav
or the line with bishop f5 which i would
consider
the main line something like knight here
e6 knight h4
and that's you know there are a lot of
variations you can play with bishop e4
bishop g4 or bishop back
um and i i would consider those more
more
mainline but
a6 is of course a very natural move too
and it kind of delays development and he
has some ideas of takes and then playing
b5 with the tempo and then c5
um so usually you know a6 is more of a
solid move
but i continued with bishop to d3
bishop g4 was played and actually this
is not what i had prepared for the game
because one thing is that um
one thing is that you know for this
tournaments usually you know your
pairings
so um so
i mean essentially uh you can prepare
for your opponent you can find their
games online if you find out they're
like on like chess.com leeches accounts
it's even better
um because you know one hasn't played
official tournaments in a while but
yeah so i think i was preparing for
something else
i think i was preparing for one of the
one of the lines
um one of the lines that i mentioned
previously but not this one
however i had a game here in 2018 i
think
and i remember some of the prep and i
also played
i think in 2020 like
summer i think i played the training
game in this line
if i'm not mistaken so i could remember
a little bit
of of how i was supposed to play but it
wasn't
it was more of like general ideas it
wasn't exactly
um move by move and this is a thing that
all of you guys can can learn about
sometimes
depends on the variation of course if
it's a really sharp line like some
knight of line
you probably do want to know the full
line by memory
but oftentimes in openings you don't
really need to do that you can kind of
learn the general ideas and then you can
determine which moves are
best at which stage and and such so yeah
um but yeah
you don't think you have ever seen me
speak
english well i i speak spanish mainly
i mean it's my first language but i
always dream in english
uh but thanks though um okay
so let's continue with the game knight
d2 was played
e6 and here i made a very particular
move i played queen c2
i played queen c2 for a reason usually
you kind of would want to play with b3
and i believe this is another mainline
move
um b3 however what i didn't like is that
after the pawn goes to e6 the bishop has
the chance to go back to f5
and essentially in this position i would
want to train my bishop for
for theirs because uh this is my good
bishop
and it controls the e4 square and it's
gonna help make like an e4 push in the
foot
in the future if i need it so um
i wouldn't really want to trade and also
you may think that after takes takes you
know
they got double pawns and that's not
good but this one actually helps control
the center
and with the help of like g6 is going to
be supported it's not going to be a weak
pawn
uh this one is not weak by any means um
so it's not like you pulled away the
fender
and it controls e4 very well it controls
the light squares
and we just trade our light square
bishop so that's not good
um and you know it's gonna be safe for
the king once the castle's church so
essentially this is not what what you
want
um but
yeah so for example after bishop f5 one
will have to play queen c2 and after
take sticks
i mean the position is still fine for
white they have to space
but it's not the same like the break
here wouldn't
it wouldn't be as strong the more the
pieces trade if that makes sense like
you don't want to open up the position
and potentially create a weak pawn
if you're trading pieces already you
want to have as many pieces as
you can so you can um keep the
initiative and maybe develop an attack
after you do a pawn break you wouldn't
necessarily just want to
to um to do a pawn break and then not
have enough pieces to support it
so that's some general stuff and that's
the reason why i decided to play queen
c2 over b3
simply because there's this idea of the
bishop going back and trading and i
didn't necessarily want to allow that to
my opponent
so um yeah
he played knight bd7 which is one of the
main lines however
uh d take c4 was another idea remember
earlier i was mentioning
that you know with a6 sometimes you can
afford to take and there are some ideas
in the future of playing b5 and c5
uh but after queen takes for example
knight d7
um y could play something like b4
to try and cut down whatever type of
future initiative they could have on the
king side on the queen side
uh but for example after bishop d3h3
you know this is just a game it's not
it's not necessarily
like uh better for white worse for white
this would just be
a completely type of game essentially
but c takes d4 was
sorry d take c4 was another another
possible variation
so um knight d7 was played
b3 i'm going to play bishop b2 have
solid control over e5 so they don't have
a pawn break themselves
um and then continue with building up my
my initiative so
bishop d6 bishop b2 queen b8 was played
um if castle there may be the but the
possibility of playing knight e5
and completely shutting down any any
chances of of white playing with e5
so that would that probably wouldn't be
what they want
therefore they played here queen b8 to
keep control over this square
castle now
um they castle i would say that e5 is
not really what you want
why do you guys think e5 wouldn't be
like the optimal move for
for black
does knight f3 before knight c3 make a
big difference it's essentially
a choice um
as you can see in this game i was more
flexible with my b1 knight so i
was managed to develop it to
to d2 rather than c3 so it doesn't get
in the in the way of my bishop
um but
you know it's just preference knight c3
is just another
slav variation um
yeah i do understand um spanish and i'm
glad that you're enjoying the stream
elvis um why not queen c7 for black
yeah so maybe that's one thing i can
mention they want the queen on b8
because my queen is already on c2 so if
the queen goes to c7 for example
let's say here um in the future there
could be like some altercation because
after c
oops sorry after c takes d5 uh
there could be some potential attack on
this file especially if you plan to play
with e5
so let's say queen c7 i castle and e5 is
played um now not only
not only is there going to be like
issues with takes
but also it kind of takes away a square
for this bishop
if the queen was on b8 it could go to c7
but now i would have to go to the
different diagonal and then e5 has
less protectors and you don't have like
the battery that you would
that you would want on this guy i don't
know if that makes sense so
the queen on ba just kind of gives more
space for for the other pieces
but yeah
um
black gets an isolated opponent on d5
kind of yeah so i mean essentially you
don't want to play d5
mainly mainly because you know the key
is on the center that's the biggest
thing
don't don't try to open up the center
when
your king could potentially be in danger
after
uh also the super shops do look really
nice towards the king side
just a little um
thing you can notice but e5
there is going to be there are going to
be some issues with the
with the pawn structure um
and the fact that you know
the pieces are not fully developed and
as was mentioned
uh there are possibilities of getting an
isolated opponent
if they take and takes with pawn so
um end this later so
there could be some issues with the pawn
structure i mean essentially we want to
take with knight
they also have this idea of knight b4 so
white usually needs to be
a bit careful about that um
[Music]
but usually we need to be a bit careful
about that but i mean essentially
with e5 you can't even take take
and i guess you could take take and
um it's just going to be
that black will have to spend some some
extra tempos in the future
like for example after it takes takes
takes takes knight c4
the knight could come to d6 if you don't
co-wrap the square
um there's bishop e2 getting the bishop
out of the way to play queen e5 so like
if queen c7 or something this should be
two and
the queen could potentially go to e5 it
could take
the pawn on h7 was kind of weak also
bishop f5 even
it just looks less pleasant
it feels like it's not it's not complete
like the development
um so
yeah it just feels like the development
is not complete and you kind of wish you
had the same position but with the king
castle
yeah so for example they
castled here and now there is this very
interesting idea
that i remember from uh some previous
training that i had
and you can play with h3 you don't
necessarily want to take right now and
give up the bishop pair for nothing
so after bishop h5 i continued with
knight g5
and this is a very interesting move
uh this is a very interesting move
because you know
it may look like well it's just a one
move thread there's not really much to
it like you're attacking h7 but they can
play
h6 and and then it's fine
um however it's it's very interesting
because it's not just that
like you can you have some interesting
ideas so for example
if they play h6 knight f3
has something changed in the position
does anyone realize
like why this line would be good for
white
i'm gonna give you a little bit of time
because i feel like it's not super
obvious
especially if you don't know the line or
you don't play it yourself
i remember this game from somewhere is
it recent i mean i played it like
the what day was it the 15th
yeah you guys are right so i mean not
exactly g4 g5
but the idea of g4 the idea of g4 is
very nice
and it's really difficult to stop and
the thing is that if you do nothing
let's say you play like rookie 8
um i have g4 taking is not really that
good because you don't have pieces to
checkmate me um i feel like that's
pretty obvious
and if bishop back i can take take
and win a pawn so the idea is that when
when they play h3
they are taking away one of the one of
the defenders of the g6 square
so when the bishop can't go back now and
in this position because of g4
they are forced to take and they are
forced to give me to give me
the bishop player so that's the whole
idea with this with this strategy
that i get the bishop pair at the end um
because you can't really stop g4
so you have to give me the bishop and
that's
that's the whole plan um of course
there's this other move
that is possible that they can do
and that move is bishop g6 straight up
defending h7 by blocking the
diagonal um however now after bishop
takes pawn takes
the position can suddenly become
uncomfortable for black
i think i checked with computer and it
gave
maybe maximum like slightly better for
for white there are games in this
position
actually uh with rookie one group e a d1
for example bringing the rook to the
center and then
uh the e5 was playing one of the games
takes takes takes and an isolated pawn
was formed
after that white had a very comfortable
position
um however i think right here
um i had some ideas of playing with c5
and
bishop c7 for example f4 so essentially
i close up the position and i take away
the only pawn break that they have
and now i can focus on moves like for
example knight of 395
and playing with g4 and developing an
attack on the king side
if that makes sense so um
yeah so i couldn't remember
like full on uh what the best
continuation was in the game but i do
remember that this was an idea
and uh no root left
yeah there could be some root lifts
eventually or like
king g2 h4h5 with the root on each one
um you can get like the knight out of
the way and the queen can come over to
the kingside um
but yeah essentially i thought that this
positions were very comfortable for
white and i wasn't really mad at going
at them
it doesn't even though the position is
closed it's not really drawish
um my rating is not
1961. um my
rating i mean fida is about 22.80 right
now
and uscf is like 23.49 i think
so yeah it's funny if my writing was
uh 1961 how could i be teaching road to
2000
yeah yeah um
anyways uh
but yeah all right
so yeah this is actually a very
interesting line this is knight g5 i
think it's a very
interesting idea there are games in it
if you guys want to check it out if you
want to maybe use it in one of your
games you think it's a good trick
i would really recommend you to to look
into it
um because you can get like good
positions relatively easy
so if you guys want you can check it out
but h6 happened
not f3 takes takes and my opponent went
for e5
straight away now he could have played
rook e8 for example and i would have
played something like rook fd1
uh queen c7 happened in a different game
however here it's very interesting to
play with c5 bishop back
and b4 and have some solid control of
the queen side
everything is pretty close top and the
most important thing we have control of
the e5 square so there is never this
e5 break and if we want later we can
bring the knight here player 4 similar
idea
and of course if a5 b5 so this is just
another uh possible way to
to play the to play the
the variation
but uh in this position my opponent
decided to go for e5 straight up
now based on the trade
that we had to move ago do you guys
think that it's a good idea to open up
the position
yeah so essentially black wouldn't want
to black would not want to
open up the position if i have the
bishop pair
and they don't essentially they want to
try and keep it closed
or more solid since they have the two
knights
um but i am not mad that he's wanting to
open up the
the position while i have the bishop
player and not only the bishop player
but the bishop
player kind of synchronized to look into
his skin sign
it's already kind of looking at that
side
and i have my queen helping too so i
mean
i i at the
at the game i couldn't remember exactly
the reason why
but i knew that playing e5 straight up
uh wasn't really wasn't really a great
idea because you know
of principles and if you guys ever are
in a position that you don't fully
understand you can try to follow the
principles to
guide yourself with moves and oftentimes
not always of course but oftentimes an
ugly move is not good
so um i wouldn't like if you don't know
if you don't know what opening you're
playing i would recommend you to just
follow
follow the principles and not really try
to find
you know the exception of the rule
because it's it's
a lot less chances for you to be right
than if you actually follow
um if you actually follow the the actual
principle so yeah
all right so if i was playing and
i knew that my position could could get
interesting after that
so of course i played uh d takes e5
otherwise uh this was a threat of course
and i don't want him to get the center
so
takes takes and i proceeded with bishop
b2
i did not want to train my bishops but i
also did not want to trade many pieces
especially because after it takes takes
uh this is kind of a pin
and i'm kind of forced to trade the
bishops somehow and if we trade the
bishops let's say i take take
uh this can begin to look rather drawish
because after takes are now going to
take with the pawn they're going to take
with the knight for example
and this position just looks kind of
drawish and it kind of takes away
whatever advantage i had before so i
didn't
want to i didn't want to just trade
every piece
and get into it more likely equal
more likely equaling game so
so yeah that's another thing you guys
should probably um
stay cautious
conscious conscious about uh when you
play
when you play games don't just trade
because you want to trade pieces like
make sure that every trade that you do
benefits you somehow
and as you can see taking here wouldn't
have benefited me so i kind of
just didn't really go for it uh because
it makes his bishop better
and it provokes a trade and it gets rid
of my pair of bishops so i
didn't want to to go for that
um and instead i went bishop e2 another
possible move was through d1
um and you're not super worried about
tapes
because after queen takes um there's
like this
pin going on here so takes is not
possible because of queen takes
and it takes takes
and also this pawn is defended by this
pawn
but mainly this knight however the
bishop is ready to take it
so for example if bishop e7
uh there's takes and if pawn takes
because of
here here look here one here
but if this move intermediate then after
it takes takes
what do you guys think of this position
caleb got and a haircut
more like he didn't get a haircut he
took some
um sugar bear hair or something and he
grew his hair out
um visually you guys like black
black is better slight advantage for
white
black has the majority on the clean side
you guys seem to be very decided on this
one it's not clear
white white is better i'll let you know
that not just slightly better but
clearly better
now what is what move do you guys think
they could make
kind of has to do with the fact that
there's a queen on b8 and that's weird
so any ideas that you guys have
yeah white does have the initiative
rook d2 and double up but you can play
with d7s right away
yeah rook d7 is best
um root d7 is best and
it's it's attacking the pawn on b7 which
is a backward spawn
that defends c6 but also it attacks f7
which is often timely
oftentimes weak week and it can't really
be defended by this bishop so i can only
be defender by
the heavier pieces
and for example of course this is not
possible because of takes
oops sorry and um if queen c8 or
something trying to get the queen out of
the way
just rook f d1 and if you look at it
like what move does black have they
don't really have a move here
um it's not easy to make a move like
let's say a5
just because white has this very strong
e4
and the you know the stag the the attack
is about to
to build up and e5 is coming
followed up by e6 the position is
opening up and it doesn't really look
good for black in any way
um yeah so this
this position is very very good for for
white
um so yeah
rook d7 is a very strong move
but yeah that would have been an option
i just decided to play bishop to e2
it's another fine move uh rook to e8 was
played rook a d1
it's important to bring all the pieces
into the center
queen c7 and now you can kind of start
thinking how can i improve my position
once again you don't really want to take
because you don't really achieve
anything
by doing so uh but you do want to try
and make your
pieces better somehow and one thing you
guys may notice is
the square on f5 especially because the
the light square bishop was traded from
black
uh the square on f5 is kind of weak at
the moment so
for example knight h4 could be could be
a
an idea and this is what i did end up
playing
and it's a very strong move because you
don't really have a way to stop the
knight from coming here
do you guys think that g6 is possible
94 was another possibility it's just
that it may get
like in the way of the bishop uh and
i mean it's completely fine it's just
that knight h4
just seems a bit clear
yeah the dark square bishop is very
happy but let's say after g6 which
definitely doesn't look like a good move
because
um because it simply just
makes the king even weaker weaker but
um what would you guys play
yeah you guys are right so f4 is very
strong here and for those of you who
haven't seen like any streams of mine my
favorite move to play is f4 oftentimes
i'm wrong about it
and it's very weakening move but my
favorite move to make is f4
and here it works great uh f4
and the only square essentially that i
can go to
is d7 and now why can't you do this
white
if you know bishop takes f6 don't think
that it's hanging and item d7 is
protecting it so
yeah now uh
yeah now you can take on g6 f5 is
probably a possibility too
but i mean you can just fake and the
idea as mentioned
is that the queen is kind of blocked
from coming to g7 and protecting
and now this knight on f6 is some big
trouble so for example let's say kh8
uh you don't even take and uh
it just looks really good for for white
not even this is possible because it
takes
but yeah so f4 and ig
knight g6 would have been a very strong
idea if they had played g6 and i think
maybe they saw it so they didn't want to
go for it
but if they don't go for it like i'm
going to get my knight on f5 and it's
gonna be a very strong night
so yeah knight f5 is that what
some of you say um but but yeah it's
it's um it's a tough position already
for
for for black
but yeah so after a knight h4 rook c8
was played
now c takes d5
and i have a question what would you
guys take on d5 with
so that is fine to see a position fall
apart oh my gosh
um
with the night one night
so many people are saying night four
people in a row have said night
um all right
so so let's
let's see
so this is what was played in the game
of course
if takes after takes takes knight f5
the pawn on d5 is very weak and most
likely
white will be able to attack it and
eventually capture it
in the end game because not only do we
have the bishop player but we have
enough
pieces to attack on e5 we have a strong
blockade before the pawn
uh it just seems like eventually it's
gonna fall
so um we're in a much better end game
however that would be
preferred to knight takes d5
and that might seem a little wild but
the reason why is because with knight d5
you're kind of pulling the knight away
from the king side
and your king is going to get a lot
weaker
so so yeah
and i'm going to explain how so knight
f5 was played
bishop to f8 not wanting to to give up
the other bishop
and now i played this move bishop c4
but there was this very strong f4 once
again
f4 and when knight g6 happened
uh how do you guys think we can keep
building up the white position
also keep in mind that e3 is kind of
hanging
do you guys have any idea of how to
bring more pieces into the game
how do you guys think we can we can
prep for for an attack here
i'm so glad you guys are finding it yeah
rook f3
um rook f3 is very strong
it is defending e3 and it can also go to
g3 later
so for example if h5 so that if look
here
upon h4 we can just play h4
and after rook d8 for example rook g3
and there's going to be a huge amount of
pressure on
on this file like there are even ideas
of
uh takes off first of all but also
knight h6 pawn takes and root takes g6
there are even ideas of that so
essentially the black position is kind
of falling apart
and every weakness from white is very
well covered
so um this would have been a very nice
idea
yeah it's comedo but it would have been
a very nice idea
so yeah um
but bishop c4 i played instead kind of
looking towards the king looking at this
uh nitrate here and after night before
queen b1 b5 he played
and i went back with my bishop but you
see that now this knight
is kind of further away from from the
play
and my opponents played with
g6 now
uh you guys know i mentioned earlier
that g6 is probably not right in this
positions
because it weakens the king a lot more
and opens up this bishop so that there
is
a lot of possibilities with the
diagonals so like you can
maybe put the queen in front of the
bishop somehow and already have some
ideas of attack
and essentially just the king looks a
whole lot weaker g6
on itself could be a weakness as we saw
in the previous variation
um but he did play the
this move in this position and i think
his idea is that he can go to g7
afterwards
and have the diagonal covered a bit more
um yeah so
it's not really it's not really a great
move but
i mean if you think about it like here
what could you do as black the position
is very uncomfortable uh maybe you could
try to go back with the knight
but that looks really bad and probably
the ideas of
f4 are even stronger now that the queen
is safer on b1
than it was on c2 so you can probably
continue with that
and then have the same idea and it will
be very unpleasant for black
also another thing is um
you know time travel happens and
we're on move 23 so essentially we
weren't on time trouble in this position
but i would say we had maybe like
half an hour to 25 minutes or at least
he did
because i remember i remember um
usually when my opponents are like 25
minutes and usually i'm staying about
the same
time against them uh usually on those
moments
um usually on those moments like
i kind of speed up and i want to play
more practical chess
and that's a thing that you guys can can
keep in mind
for like your own game is i understand
that playing more
classical style games is not as common
now but even like
rapid games um
even rapid games you know just keep in
mind trying to play
faster as you're approaching time
control but
faster in a sense of like not just
gotta go fast speed uh more of like you
know try to set up tricks for your
opponent
for them to fall into essentially it's
what would be recommended
and for that you need tactics and if you
know me you know that i'm always
recommending people to do tactics
because they're
they're never wrong they're never bad
so do tactics you know and it can help
you
i was doing a lot of calculation before
this tournament
and i know that calculation is not fun i
was
doing like those really annoying like
artistic
mating three mating four and those are
not fun
but i play good in my tournament because
of that later so
um i recommend you guys to do tactics
and calculation
often do some puzzle rush before your
online tournament
um just make sure that you're warmed up
awake agile sharp i don't know
but yeah oh you guys are saying
f4 in this position
um f4
maybe f4 is fine yeah
i think f4 is a good move here uh
because it's really difficult to move us
as black if the knight goes back
if the knight goes back it just looks
very very uncomfortable
um i would say
actually i'm not that concerned about
this phone like you can probably find
ways
to not lose it but i'm not actually even
that concerned about it
i think you can probably even just go
back with the knight
um but it does look it does look like
a good move of course and if this
you could take with bishop you can take
with pawn i think both of them are fine
i like bone because then you can take
with queen next move
um but yeah f4 would have been a nice
move
uh i just played knight g3 because i
thought it made sense and i can maybe
bring my knight to e4
um
so oh you guys are saying that h4 yeah
knight h4 is
even another move uh i think here
yeah knight h4 and there are some ideas
of takes
and that's probably not good for for
black
um but yeah i just play knight g3 which
is also fine and i had some ideas of
doing this
that's the reason why i went to g3 uh
how can
unadvanced players learn to do
calculation
i would say probably the easiest way is
like chess websites like
you can probably check out like chess
tempo or
like even the chess 24 sorry chess.com
regular puzzles
like not by speed not puzzle rush like
the regular ones
um you can also just find some book
[Music]
i would say
the complete tactical workout i think is
a name those were really good
um i think those were really good
um calculation
and visualization go hand by hand so you
can also do blindfold exercises
those are also very very good and for
that if you're really bad at it you can
start with like
simple position with very few pieces and
then you can move on to like a middle
game position for example
and of course recreating them so like
you see them
and then you turn away and then you
recreate them on the board like you set
up piece by piece and you make sure that
it's all right
uh and from then you can move on to like
solving
uh easy puzzles but blindfolded
um or you can grab like a full game
memorize it and then play it out on the
board and usually i don't know i think
those those helps too
i remember i used to do that a lot on
earlier years
of mine funny to say early years when
i'm like pretty young but
yeah um okay
but yeah i just continued with knight g3
and after knight d5 queen c1
um i like this move because it protects
e3 so i had some ideas of f4
also some ideas of e4 and then i can't
go to f4
so yeah
knight d7 let's play bishop to g4
and f5 and would you guys take it
or go back or do nothing about it
um i don't practice blindfold that much
but i'm kind of getting into playing
like
blindfolded on leachates you know that
they have that feature
so i'm kind of getting into it but i
mean
having at least some basic skill of
memorizing the chess board
is really important so i would really
recommend that and
you know for those positions that are
complicated we need to visualize
uh it's important that you don't make
the mistake of like
placing a piece in the wrong place uh
like you know
trading a piece in your calculation and
then um thinking that it's still
there later in the line just simply
because it's in front of you in the
chess board because
it doesn't really move as you're
calculating so
uh it's just important that you are able
to do your calculations right
and for that you need to visualize well
um
so
yeah bishop f3 is um is a possibility
bishop f3 is actually what i play in the
game um
and i was trying to put my opponent like
under pressure because we were reaching
time trouble
but um knight f5 is actually another
idea too
knight takes f5 and after takes
bishop takes rookie 7 for example they
have to start covering up the seventh
rank like the two bishops are killers
essentially from this side on this side
even depends
um but now e4
knight f6 and how do you bring more
pieces over
because remember you can't checkmate
with like two pieces most of the time
you need to bring all of your pieces
into the attack
yeah rook lift very nice we have had a
a bunch of uh interesting rook lifts uh
examples in this game today
also rook d3 is kind of foreshadowing
don't forget about it
but yeah rook uh d3 and then you can
bring the rook over
um the queen uh can attack
h6 eventually also it can come to c3
um so yeah but i mean the position is
super uncomfortable even ideas of e5 in
the future
however i just played bishop f3 i played
a bit calmer
and after knight f6 i continued with
rookie 1 trying to play e4
my opponent played 94 and after
take steaks i decided to take with
bishop i remember i was calculating
takes takes and bishop here
um but i didn't know how to
how to continue after and i didn't want
to allow my opponents to have enough
time to play something like bishop g7
and be more solid so always remember to
not give
enough chances or moves to your opponent
so yeah
so that's why i played bishop takes
sometimes you gotta say bye bye to the
beautiful
bishop pair but the ideas after it takes
i have rook d4
queen a5 was played my opponent i think
did the right thing they were trying to
find some sort of active
counter play however the queen is moving
away from the king side it's moving
really far
really far away actually and this is
going to be a
problem because even if they manage to
take pawns
like the queen is going to be so far
away that i'm gonna have enough
compensation with my kingside attack if
that makes sense
so yeah bishop pair
i mean you kind of have to be smart too
and decide
when you want to to trade
certain pieces
[Music]
to improve your position and
now we're seeing mostly like tactics in
the position so
one needs to be fast and one needs to
to have threats and taking with the
bishop would have just been better in
that position
uh queen d1 is what you're looking at um
quindy one maybe bishop g7
um
but um
it's kind of like quindy one i don't
think that's the piece you want to do it
with
i kind of did it with the rook also so
that
so that um there wouldn't be like a
queen attacking my rook and i would have
to defend it with my own queen
for the rest of the game i just kind of
got rid of that problem also the regular
one wasn't doing anything anymore
so it makes sense to bring it to a
better square keep the queen here
um and you know ready for some ideas of
queen c3 with the time ever comes
or you know put pressure on e4 attack it
take it
then play e4 and then have some ideas
with the queen coming to this side
uh but queen takes a2 was playing
queen takes a2 was played um
and now what would you guys take on e4
with
well you guys check on on e4 with the
record
of the night
oh you guys are saying night
all right a lot of people most people
are saying night
rook it clears the diagonal for the
bishop
yeah so by this point i would say we're
kind of at
like 10 minutes maybe he has some time
less he actually had less time than me
so maybe he had like two minutes and i
had like about 10 minutes
uh maybe seven minutes like two minutes
to seven minutes more or less
so we were kind of getting onto the time
trouble and this tournament it's very
interesting it didn't have like any
extra time at move 40
so if you get on time trouble then
you're kind of it for the rest of the
game like you need to play fast for the
rest of the game
uh hopefully the the online
chess training for like a full year um
helped but um
yeah time travel is not fun rook a4
unfortunately
rook a4 we want to do it but the plum
can take it
and then we'll lose our rook and that's
not really
great um
but i took on e4 with the rook however
however um this was kind of a mistake it
was much better to take with the knight
to take with a knight and then have
ideas of rook takes d5 and knight f6
and also knight d6 if the bishop comes
to g7
so take away the knight would have been
a lot better
however i took with the rook and the
issue with this is that there could have
been
rook takes takes and queen b3
and um now it's not so clear like you
would think that rook takes d5
could be could be
could be good but there are there are
some tactics so for example
you don't want to trade take with the
queen because of knight f6
uh but if pawn takes takes
um they can take here
and you know this diagonal is covered by
the queen it's not super simple actually
and they have these two pawns the queen
can get in it's not
it's not pleasant for white actually so
so yeah
um so for example in this position
i would probably have to play something
like um
something like bishop e5 and the
position i think it's about equal
because i'm gonna have some attack on
the key side
and that's gonna be um of good use
but they do have these phones and they
are very very scary so
um it would just have kind of taken away
too much from my position
however thankfully after this he decided
to take him b3 straight up
and thankfully there was no um
thankfully there was no no
counter play but
now we have a very clear threat i think
uh you guys probably see it i don't i'm
not going to ask you actually
um you go g4 it makes sense you're going
after the weak phone
um f5 sorry g5 just looks
really bad there are some ideas of e4
actually and after the knight comes back
rook takes g5 i remember i was looking
into this
during the game because the bishop is
helping
so my opponent here played king 2 h7
now after
this what do you guys think i played
how do you bring the piece that is not
doing
much right now into the game
f4 that may be a little bit slow
rook takes g6 there's kind of no need to
right now
you have an easier move
continue bringing pieces in but at the
same time making threats
bishop f6 there could be night takes so
be careful
um quimby one you guys are recommending
queen bee one
and yeah that's actually the the correct
move you're bringing the queen in
while at the same time making a very
dangerous threat onto on to g6
so uh for example if they play something
like knight to e7
there is going to be rook 2 to
um d7 like the knight
now that gets out of the way the rook
can conjoin
and if queen f7 defending i had a very
interesting move in mind
to play here i had thought about knight
g5
i thought this move was kind of funny uh
knight h5
and the ideas that you can't take
because of you know
the pin and um i'm also threatening
knight to f6
and it's very difficult to stop because
g7 is also covered
so this is what i had planned to play if
um
if uh he had played knight back to e7
but it just looks extremely
uncomfortable it looks like
they're about to lose in a couple of
moves even the idea of knight f4
with you know putting in more pressure
on two onto
g6 is is a thing so
um it just looks extremely
extremely bad for for black
and of course they don't have to play
knight e7 they can play the move that
they played in the game
which is rook to e6 however
why to move and win
what do you guys think
any ideas
how are you guys finish up this position
knight to e4 knight to
f5
[Music]
uh
yeah i think you guys are seeing it
not a five not a five is interesting but
also kind of
unnecessary
oh and the last position with the pins
yeah i get it
um
yeah you guys are getting it uh remember
how i mentioned that rook d3
was kind of foreshadowing for how the
game ended
uh rook b4 is not winning it's not
really necessary
uh you can just play rook d3 and
actually
um funny enough the queen is trapped it
doesn't really have any square to go to
and it's protected oh sorry and the rook
is protected by the queen of course
knight f3 was played but after takes
queen d5
rook d3 my opponent resign because there
is no way to stop rook d7
so like let's say queen here
i can probably play bishop a6 actually
but i mean i have ideas of coming in
with my rook so
well let's say bishop bishop a6
that's probably winning and then i can't
come in here i mean i have a piece up so
almost anything i do is winning um
but i can also play like rook here if i
want to and then bishop e7
and um
gosh anything is winning probably bishop
d4 is good enough
someone had ideas of knight of five so
nine to five here
that's probably crashing too um
yeah i mean i'm kind of just a piece up
so but yeah in this position my opponent
resigned
and um it was uh
it was a very okay look changed
uh caleb is on a vacation and instead
you have me
uh so um for now you guys are going to
be
seeing me over his classes and you guys
shouldn't go anywhere because i'm going
to be doing
uh the in-game class right after now
and later i'm going to be analyzing your
games
on twitch so you guys should definitely
stay tuned
for the upcoming couple of hours
um so uh
yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this game
and i hope you guys um
i don't know learned something from it i
hope you guys like the
opening idea and maybe you can consider
it for your games
so so yeah i hope you guys liked it
um i'm glad to see you guys are liking
it
all right so i think i think i'm going
to
end the stream for now but don't go
anywhere because i'm going to
start over again with um
with endgame so
stay tuned stay tuned we're going to
look at a
magnus in game so
uh definitely stay here
um yeah
oh also um i have a youtube channel
teletali26
also twitch channel 26
you guys should definitely check those
out because i
post there but don't go anywhere i'll be
back
in a sec bye bye